it's Friday and it means it's time for
[Music]
tonight's edition a Halloween costume is
causing outrage blessed be to tell us
about it we're joined by New York Times
bestselling author of the forthcoming
will Wilder the amulet our Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo Raymond what
costume is driving the PC crowd cradle
you and everyone will remember at the
Kavanagh hearing there were those women
who dressed up in the costumes from
Handmaid's Tale the Hulu series now
these are women who are forced into
surrogacy in the process of this
miniseries well a website called Yandy
which specializes in lingerie launched a
brand new string of Halloween costumes
including this one which depicted the
the costume of the handmade skill well
women took to Twitter and said wait a
minute rape is not funny rape victims
are not funny and they said this must be
taken down the fictional characters
being lampooned and sexualized in this
way was outrageous so the company took
it down in a statement they said over
the last few hours it's become obvious
that the Andi brave red maiden costume
is being seen as a symbol of women's
oppression rather than an expression of
women's empowerment so they took it down
now Laura I then went to the Andi
website and looked at some of their
other offerings just to see what was
there because you want to buy something
that we're like I don't look what I
found bad habbit nun costume what I
found this one the religious sisters
foster Britney Spears then the sexy
schoolgirl uniform and the study date
schoolgirl and this is only a sampling I
can't join any other studying that
there's not much less a lot to study
there here's the problem it's okay to
sexualize young girls nuns but fictional
characters are off-limits this is where
the culture is sending one message we
have to respect women not objectify them
which is the right message and on the
other hand giving them only costumes
during this season that sexualizes and
objectifies them including being
religiously insensitive as your sawmill
I can't believe you can't even wear
Indian and
costumes of things well actually this
site I hate crime ecology of Americans
they have the sexy sexy a good naughty
naughty Native American now as you know
Laura Hollywood is all in on the midterm
fight and the Cavanaugh battle earlier
this week Hollywood a-listers like
Julianne Moore America Ferrera and
others recorded a homemade video
supporting the Cavanaugh accuser they
thanked her for coming forward well now
Jesus Christ Superstar himself John
Legend has emerged with his own home
video he's apparently now a
constitutional scholar look who becomes
the next Supreme Court justice is the
decision of a lifetime your lifetime
Brett Cavanaugh's troubling views on the
issues that matter most and his rushed
confirmation process make him unfit for
a lifetime appointment to the Supreme
Court this fall your senators will vote
on Kavanagh how they vote will impact
you for a lifetime tell them to vote no
on Kavanagh you see his wife is a is a
beautiful I think super model but she
has tweeted the nastiest stuff about the
president Nats fine if you're entitled
to their opinion here's my problem is
talented their opinion is only as valid
as anybody else's diet they're very
talented people we don't need their
constitutional exegesis I mean unless
you're paying Thurgood Marshall or
something we don't want to hear from you
just sing my songs be happy oh you're
gonna say shut up and I'm not gonna say
shut up in anything but okay well where
is the Hollywood activism on behalf of
people like Keith Ellison's accuser the
Clinton accusers we need those voices
too this is a little this is bothersome
that it's kind of all one-sided and not
spread out use your celebrity across the
board now Ben & Jerry's is now also
involved in this midterms they have
appointed seven new candidates that they
picked out at random left-leaning
candidates and they want people to pick
a flavor that most captures the essence
of those candidates well I looked at not
only they but their competitors I think
what we're dealing with is rocky road
cotton-candy policies I think you've got
cuckoos and cream in most cases a lot of
fruitcake Mud Pie and a Ben and Jerry's
flavor that already exists when you look
at some of these candidates you know
Shelby hubby I think what
oh yeah just to feel look like now the
me to movement has spurred so many
things created so many things it's also
birthed a new phenomena called modern
masculinity watch this it's being
marketed to Millennials it takes one
man's courage to start a chain reactions
is what it takes so we sit here and
somebody is really feeling something and
he has the balls to stand up and say I'm
really sad right now and then you check
in you watch the rest of the group as
that man says that and they just what do
you think these are these are retreats
here's a nice emotes hold me back that
is hot you know what the problem with
this sexy well unlike religious retreats
where it's about your relationship with
God your relationship with others this
is all about my feelings they gaze into
each other's eyes these men while they
have issues about body image and
sexuality buddy you know what they need
Burbank Retreat they need lessons in how
to be dads how to be have fulfilled the
duties of manhood that will teach you
masculinity more than gazing at your bro
and wondering how he thinks my pecs are
today I mean this is kind of I this is
what happens when you let Silicon Valley
come up with retreats for men I thought
you said Silicon Valley well it's gonna
be like the calf implants this is
silicone manhood by the posterior
implant you have many more segments
thank you all right